la parole est à notre collègue jacques
legendre pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur nous avons tous été émus par
le drame qui s'est produit fin ou dans
un camp de gens du voyage à roye dans la
somme et qui a coûté la vie à trois
personnes de cette communauté a battu
par un forcené et un gendarme qui
tentait de s'interposer mais l'émotion
ne peut pas excuser les incidents qui
ont suivi
à l'occasion de l'enterrement des
victimes parce que la justice n'avait
pas autorisé deux parents des victimes
condamné à de la prison a assisté aux
obsèques des membres de cette communauté
ont coupé le 28 ou l'autoroute a1 paris
lille dans les deux sens
causant d'importants dégâts à la
chaussée et provoquant 50 km de bouchons
sur l'a1 l'a16 et l'a29 pendant des
heures en cette soirée de grand retour
de vacances sur ordre du préfet la
gendarmerie n'est pas intervenue et n'a
procédé à aucune interpellation
quant à la cour d'appel elle s'est
réunie en urgence pour revenir sur la
décision du juge d'application des
peines et autoriser les personnes
incarcérées a assisté aux obsèques
une une telle affaire pose bien des
questions
pourquoi la justice at-elle refusé ce
qu'elle a ensuite accepté en urgence
pourquoi les forces de l'ordre ne sont
elles pas intervenu alors qu'il y avait
un trouble manifeste à l'ordre public
quel est le coût de cette affaire qui va
payer les travaux de remise en état de
l'autoroute qui va compenser les pertes
de recettes que la société
concessionnaire peut réclamer
monsieur le président de la république
questionné à ce sujet s'est déclaré
profondément désolé pour les
désagréments causés mais a déclaré ne
pas vouloir mettre en danger les forces
de l'ordre nous le comprenons bien mais
cet aveu de faiblesse c'est quand même
très inquiétant
il rappelle la choquante mansuétude dont
ont bénéficié les hadîths notre dame des
landes loire atlantique où plus de 200
exactions ont été commises
y compris fin ou contre des gendarmes
sans véritable réaction des autorités
ont une
que dire de la situation aussi à calais
le 2 septembre
quant à l'entrée dû tunnel sous la
manche un eurostar avec 704 passagers à
bord est resté bloqué de 21h30 à 10h30
le lendemain matin à cause de la
présence de migrants sur les voies
monsieur le ministre
quand l'autorité reculent devant les
violents c'est la république qui
s'affaiblit défendre la république c'est
d'abord faire appliquer la loi
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
bernard cazeneuve pour 2030 maximum
monsieur le monsieur le sénateur
legendre vous êtes un excellent
commentateur d'une situation que vous
avez avec vos amis contribuer à créer et
je vais m'expliquer mais je vais
m'expliquer parce que monsieur le
sénateur legendre quand quand pendant
cinq ans quand pendant cinq ans on
supprime pas quand pendant cinq ans on
supprime 15 unités de forces mobiles 15
unités de forces mobiles
quand pendant cinq ans on supprime 13
mille agents dans les forces de l'ordre
7000 dans la gendarmerie et 6000 dans la
police quand pendant cinq ans avec une
méticulosité absolue on s'emploie à
affaiblir les forces de l'ordre on se
dispense de donner des leçons à ceux qui
doivent faire face à une situation
difficile et qui mobilise des forces de
l'ordre pour y faire face c'est ça la
réalité
deuxièmement deuxièmement vous n'étiez
pas là le soir où s'est passé ce drame j
étais moi à l'hôpital d'amiens
j'étais aux côtés des gendarmes qui
avaient perdu l'un des leurs et j'ai vu
l'émotion parmi les forces de
gendarmerie
au moment où ce drame s'est produit j'ai
également vu le climat d'extrême tension
qui existait à ce moment là et il est
des moments où il est de la
responsabilité de l'état de ne pas
ajouter des morts aux morts est de faire
en sorte
lorsqu'il ya une situation de ce type
est dans la responsabilité plutôt que
d'être dans l'exploitation d'une
situation à des fins politiques
avec des arguments populistes qui sont
ceux que vous venez d'utiliser à
l'instant enfin le troisième argument
que je voudrais développer monsieur le
sénateur et je vais vous le dire très
franchement laissé à penser que sur ce
sujet il puisse y avoir une quelconque
faiblesse de l'état alors même qu'au
lendemain de cet événement les enquêtes
ont été enclenchées qu'elle se
poursuivre pour rattraper ceux qui ont
commis ces actes et les punir les plus
sévèrement possible c'est aussi
alimenter un populiste qui ne fait pas
de bien à la république bien